i saw in the news today talking about  the violence  in foreign countries  talking about all the savagery up in the  world  but they never talk about south central  [Music]  they never talk about what happened to  my brother  now he's gone now i ain't got no brother  yo dog  i'll be your brother really  absolutely dark you're gonna need  somebody to lean on  you can't just be walking around here  where there's emptiness in your heart  man and emptiness that can only  be filled by a brother  [Music]  okay brothers man  [Music]  brother  brothers man come here man why don't you  keep following me around man why don't  you go home  and stay out of my room nobody don't  mess with my models i'm about to get a  wedding  hey you don't give a grown man a wedgie  [ __ ] i'm 34 years old  i got grandchildren